so there's also a whole set of informal
institutions that have grown up over the
past 30 years really is a function of
globalization itself that our networks
of national government officials with a
central bankers have been talking to
each other for 30 40 years securities
commissioners insurance supervisors
antitrust officials environmental
officials even judges and to some extent
legislators are talking to their
counterparts abroad so instead of some
vast international bureaucracy what you
got are these networks of national
government officials who are talking to
each other just like corporate officials
are or if you're in a non-governmental
organization you know all your
counterparts around the world and those
institutions are they exist they are
they've been meeting for many years but
we're not using them in any productive
way we're not recognizing the existence
of a global financial network and saying
no wait a minute let's connect that to
the IMF let's connect that to the g7 the
g8 or the g20 and let's have some formal
institutions that are more
representative of the world but let's
hook them on to these informal
institutions that can move quickly that
have access to the people on the ground
and every nation in the world and let's
figure out how to use those networks so
that they're not just talking to each
other they're actually coordinating
policy and implementing new ideas